[Music]
Comcast movie borrows the beginning of
2001 hoping to fool us into thinking
this will be great also narration life
was given to a civilian years ago I see
they got the voice of her to narrate
this movie what's next the voice of the
Shawshank Redemption how about giving
voiceover duties to actors for once what
if we down with that Luc Besson
continues with his what have humans done
with life conceit from the Fifth Element
oh good this saves me the trouble of
having to fast forward it myself also
opening montage of humanity scolding is
entirely Asian for some reason you see
roll credits that was fast but also
inevitable with this movie I guess and
why don't you do it yourself the last
think the guys expecting is the total 10
turning ups to deliver the case yeah man
people getting shady packages love
surprises I could have sniffed out this
bull in two seconds I'm going home
because I have exams on my name why the
American Lucy has classes in Taipei is
not important hey look it's Scarlett
Johansson she's pretty you know what the
other day I was in this museum no you
weren't
you're flashing your prettiest smile and
bounce which rodent metaphor is worse
this one are the one at the end of The
Departed I'm going with this one it's
the first time this week I'm showing up
in the same hotel but the same cowboy
hat too why don't you just can change up
your disguise further if I'm Lucy I'm
wondering why it matters that the guy
shows up in the same outfit isn't he
just delivering a package to a guy who
was expecting said package okay so you
can cause a scene now if you'd like cops
will come shortly meanwhile these
workers shrug off the woman yelling out
in the plaza and continue to look for
people to help that aren't there this
movie has twice used wildlife footage to
hammer home already obvious analogies so
is this a film school project or what
not even six minutes in and I'm already
concerned about how much of this short
movies run time is devoted to stock
nature footage when you bought your
tickets to Lucy you didn't know you were
buying tickets to the Discovery Channel
but you were soon corrected on that
misconception this penthouse comes at a
discount because it has no bathroom to
wash your bloody hands in also not only
are you not satisfactorily cleaning your
hands that is also a huge waste of
delicious bottled water also Eddie on
said you know where we'd like our
product placement and three executives
spontaneously said washing the guy's
bloody hands after he kills the guy and
the rest is history
wants to know what's in the case I don't
know what's in the kid do you speak
English damn girl didn't he just not ask
that question back in English I know you
told him you didn't know anything but
just answer the question I would have
subtracted a million sins if this
exploded right here and killed Lucy well
with the story event I don't know but I
would have been on the edge of my seat
no matter what oh good they have a
junkie on retainer also you bring an
already high beyond words dude to
determine the potency of your purple
powder drug this is where life as we
know it begins exposition by symposium
movie thinks that it can earn some
gravitas points by cutting to Morgan
Freeman rambling about science but ruby
has overestimated the power of Morgan
Freeman but it isn't until we reached
human beings at the top of the animal
chain that we finally see a species use
more of its cerebral capacity and then
the symposium was immediately shut down
by scholars professors and
eight-year-old children who know that
10% bullshit has long been debunked 10%
may not seem like much but it's a lot if
we look at all we've done wicked things
we've done with it montage oh the
Philippine prisoner viral video dancers
sure why not Sistine Chapel we're just
creating filler here like pink slime and
fast-food beef no reason to use logic we
can equate stuff like the building of
the pyramids and irrigation with the
solving of a Rubik's Cube apparently the
only living being that uses its brain
better than us the dolphin is this the
scientific myths folk science symposium
man they got a lot of people for this
maybe that 10% claim is right Miss Lucy
brought into the room before all the
other drug mules who were all brought in
together its 2014 but the best way these
guys can think to smuggle their drugs is
inside a couple of kidnapped human
bodies seriously that is quite possibly
the most dangerous expensive needlessly
complicated way to transport drugs I can
think of especially since you only have
like 18 people gonna sell this I know
shocking that this drug of a
crystal-blue persuasion would be for
sale most primitive beings like us and
is he still talking if his habitat is
not sufficiently favorable or nurturing
this movie must have been co-produced by
Shutterstock the cell will choose
immortality so how do you choose
immortality again I choose to live
forever
in other words self-sufficiency and
self-management no there are no other
words for immortality other than Athan
Asia the word you're looking for is
survival on the other hand if the
habitat is favorable to
but I've somehow gone to the concession
stand 15 times during this movie I
didn't realize it until a guy yelled at
my stack of cups to sit down they will
choose to reproduce nature porn montage
also this animal fucking montage is
brought to you by a director I am now
convinced is just fuckin with you hey
wait a minute
he said if the habitat is favorable they
reproduce this is clearly Los Angeles
this birthing montage proves will sit
through anything as long as Morgan
Freeman is talking how exactly do you
save time when you have a scheduled
flight that goes to a place in a
definite amount of time all bad guys are
rapists also if you work in a business
where people carry around their stomachs
is this ever a good idea well it looks
like dr. house just figured out what the
hell's going on with Lucy's body right
now
also this movie thinks we don't know
that the drugs are leaking out into her
bloodstream without showing it to us
this movie is the most dead horse
beating this movie I've ever seen wow
this drug allows the user to defy the
laws of physics yep she's on the damn
ceiling now yet somehow we're not
flashing two shots of bats and dangling
spiders and to hammer that point on if
we could access let's say 20% of our
brain's capacity movie takes ridiculous
debunked premise and decided to get like
a blow-up doll it's up to us to push the
rules and laws and go from evolution to
revolution okay that's not funny
it's not a joke it's at best a rhyme
stop laughing
come control of matter but now we're
entering into the realm of science
fiction what you mean just now this guy
didn't see under the skin and he falls
for this this food would almost
certainly have blood and brains on it
instead movie suggests you can shoot
four people at a table without even a
single drop of blood spilling on the
table itself hey that's really racist
and did she just shoot an innocent taxi
driver there wait for me why would he
wait for you also didn't we see you
flying a minute ago this drug that
maximizes your brain capacity also
somehow uploads all languages and
translations of all words to your brain
at once or is the movie saying that a
maximized human brain could literally be
fluent in any language at the first
sight of it I also love how no notices
or cares about her open carrying in a
hospital
this drug opens up 100% of your mental
capacity but a side effect is that it
makes you 100% evil anyway oh thank
goodness there goes my moral quandary I
know she's holding them at gunpoint and
they're scared but wouldn't any
well-trained doctor change masks and
gloves before operating on a new patient
I feel everything space wow she just
told her mom a lot of insane shit that
lasted nearly one minute of screen time
and her mom is just now saying they have
a bad connection in the cat it was so
soft
Siamese with blue eyes and a broken tail
she just told you she did for the taste
of your milk in my mouth just because
you think of something doesn't mean you
have to say it out loud sounds like
you're on drugs so I'll let you go for
now
we'll talk later sweetie and how long
will it take my body to eliminate the
rest of it well since I definitely know
what this drug is and what compounds
make it up it's logical that you would
ask me that question I'm gonna go with
12th pregnant women manufactures see bh4
in the sixth week of pregnancy if you
say so it once gives the fetus the
necessary energy to form all the bones
in its body I don't know sounds like
bullshit
I guess when it's science fiction you
can just make up anything about the
human body even if it's easily debunked
and when it sounds completely idiotic oh
she can see Gaia wait that cabbie who
watched her shoot another cabbie who she
told plant for me actually waited for
her what is this rapidly advancing human
brain that knows all languages and
concea trees life essence still need two
shots to kill this dude learning is
always a painful process wait why isn't
she magically speaking Korean right now
reading with the signs were saying at
the hospital and she wants to be
understood right like this grinding
under the skin roll quit oh wait that's
the wrong movie like this pain you're
experiencing it's blocking you from
understanding I think it's the English
that's blocking him from understanding
so this is how the human brain retains
information when I need to remember
where I sent all my drug mules a
sweeping camera goes around and finds
images of their plane tickets which all
just so happened to be exposed perfectly
so that I can read them funny it was
morning when professor Horton first
started talking in this movie I have no
proof of that it's just what I feel is
right
maximizing the human brain's ability to
multitask does not maximize this laptops
processors ability to perform this many
functions at once without overheating
also movie from a studio owned by
Comcast shows internet speeds not
possible with Comcast oh man they
completely misspelled Morgan Freeman on
this page I'm left
with no less than 1700 34 pages I can
recite them to all by heart if you wish
Scarlett Johansson really is playing
Samantha from her again it's like they
combined her weird science and limitless
all into one movie
I read your theory on the use of the
brain's capacity it's a little
rudimentary but you're on the right
track if you know so much why did you
need to call him again
is it because he's Morgan Freeman why
didn't she just call the cell phone in
the first place
no sure she can figure out exactly what
hotel he's staying at and called that
number but not his cell phone quantum
physics applied mathematics I would
rather just watch the stock nature
footage over this audio the rest of the
film is that an option on the DVD
kidneys aren't functioning efficiently
your livers failing you you need to make
some lifestyle changes you don't need to
know how I know this life's a mystery
explanations are for closers only okay
here's Scarlett Johansson probably in a
lot of people's top five hottest women
ever no doubt gets boggled everywhere
she goes and she turns into a brunette
without even one asshole noticing and
there are tons of people behind her
hello this guy's looking straight at her
and doesn't think this is weird huh
still haven't walked past that store yet
you've been walking constantly we've
never seen you stop but you're still
walking past this same damn store movie
tells us how much Lucy is using her
brain but doesn't really have any idea
what that means what could she do now
that she couldn't before about to arrive
in Europe each one is carrying a kilo of
drugs she just said that right at the
customs counter in the airport does this
drug sniffing dog detect the very new
and rare CPH for in her system in case
she confused it with berlin british
columbia in case you confused it with
Paris Bolivia in case you confuse it
with Rome Georgia you know the country
not the state have you got a lock-up HC
yes one of those fantastic conversations
where one guys speaking Italian and the
French guy is speaking English back what
is on those screens matrix code it's
worth another sin that there are no
consumer laptops capable of warp speed
processing like this I suppose you're
gonna tell me that she Tim tailored them
open and added more power right she's
probably just now realizing damn I could
have flown myself to Paris technology
toasting oneself
this guy isn't screaming that's Lucy
dust don't breathe that sir her logic is
I'm literally turning to dust because of
this drug
let's take more oh hey look her face is
turning into birthday sprinkles she was
turning to dust right geez I guess the
human brain is literally limitless with
increased capacity she's going to being
beamed to planet Vulcan without a
transporter at the end of the movie I
bet narcolepsy I'm gonna drive why can't
you just fly by now this one way well eh
why did the cops take her to this place
but all three of the other drug mules
went to a regular ass hospital is it
because they needed to have this car
seen all so Lucy is a dick to Paris also
why didn't your amazing bringing Google
map the best route before you started
driving
Lucy obviously kills lots of people on
her way to wherever she's going also why
doesn't she just mind-control all the
other drivers to stop driving hey guys
here's some stuff we could use to become
just like Lucy you know the amazing
abilities that our boss mr. Channing
truly told us about after Sheen liked
his hands and figured out where all
those drug mules were going by reading
his mind but now our drug operation is
probably way more important hilarious
dying tickles give me the case can you
not just force I mean I do not
understand this movie yeah because that
seems possible after what you just
witnessed a few movie she's in a hurry
dicks she already wiped out twice as
many opponents in a similar hallway by
instantly knocking them unconscious with
her brain after levitating three guys
Lucy decides this guy needs to have a
painful crash through a wall this movie
has the balls to suggest that not only
does this guy look over at the right
time and happen to see Lucy but Lucy all
knowing things about the universe Lucy
is not able to tell she's been spotted
because this movie is a real son of a
bitch actually it's an aggressive
dickhead of a film call none together a
few of my colleagues to discuss your
case tockman's in their field and very
translated um what did he just say
tockman's in their field did he say top
men's in their field the subtitles say
mines but that is not what he said no
time for extra takes I guess can you
give us an example
your daughter Gabrielle aged six died in
a car accident okay now can you do it
without being a total dick that's the
next question
because I have the antidote to
witchcraft for men coming here can you
secure the room I need to stay focused
Oh both you could knock them all out
right here and now and it take you a
nanosecond stop making shit up so that
some kind of human obstacle will be
possible for her right now you all the
cops driving up to this building mister
show going on right behind them a thing
makes no difference it's all the same
and yet my mind still needed the human
French cop to deal with the incoming
hoods because I need to focus
filmic are speeding down a road speed up
the image infinitely the car disappears
so what proof do we have of its
existence time gives legitimacy to its
existence this whole time explanation
thing is set up to blow my mind
but even if what she's saying is true
and I'm pretty sure it isn't it doesn't
seem like it has any practical use for
me or the movie on the whole here are
many deaths Lucy didn't prevent because
she needed to focus you won't be able to
hold it for much longer
time to go then what well I just knocked
them all out god damn it this movie
should be fun over roll credits
Lucy wins and becomes heir I don't think
care what happens except that what's
actually happening is ludicrous what is
she doing she's looking for energy and
matter I don't know was the correct
response and she's trying to convert the
dialogue computers I'm still trying to
figure out why this couldn't wait she
could have easily disposed of all the
bad guys and then done this but drama
I guess why are millions of bullets
hitting this statue it's not one person
standing near the statue 80% is the
matrix as you see here bazooka relay
race can they see her the people in New
York didn't they all want Pasteur like
dumb bitch at a chair in New York man
Lucy meets Lucy none of these doctor
dudes even remotely tries to stop this
attacker from shooting her CGI liquid
things how close do you need to get dude
good job waiting too long to shoot her
asshole naked Scarlett Johansson is
somewhere and I need to go to the fourth
dimension to see it amazing balls out
accelerated supercomputer gives dr.
Morton a flash drive and you know it's
amazing because it's all sparkly and
this guy still has a flip phone in 2014
something about time I forgot what a
minute
life was given to us a billion years ago
repeated narration now you know what to
do with it I really don't but cool
nature movie yo
erased from existence
[Music]
yet across the Gulf of space intellects
vast and cool and unsympathetic regarded
our planet with envious eyes we did the
wrong thing the last ever dolphin
message was misinterpreted as a
surprisingly sophisticated attempt to do
a double backward somersault through a
hoop while whistling the star-spangled
banner but in fact the message was this
so long and thanks for all the fish war
that's a full rainbow over where
[Music]
the fourth dimension will collapse upon
itself you stupid bitch to have an
echolocation system that is more
efficient than any sonar invented by
mankind
you took my sonar concept and applied it
to every phone in the city with half the
city feeding you saw now you can image
all of Gotham this is wrong